[موسيقى]
هذه هي أبواب حي الملهى الليلي في سيول
مغلقة حتى إشعار آخر
، حيث يتم اختبار العديد من الرعاة للتحقق من فيروس كورونا ،
ويقول المسؤولون إنهم اختبروا أكثر من
10000 شخص حتى الآن بعد أن زار شخص مصاب
يبلغ من العمر 29 عامًا خمسة أندية مختلفة في
وقت سابق من هذا الشهر ، وفاز رئيس بلدية سيول بارك
- يقود قريباً الجهود المبذولة لتتبع
كل شخص كان في المنطقة
على مدار أسبوعين في 19 هو أفضل
وقت يجب الانتهاء منه خلال هذا
الأسبوع يستخدم Park جميع التقنيات
المتاحة لتتبع سجلات الهاتف المحمول الخاصة بالمريض
بطاقات الائتمان CCTV  وكانت
المقابلة الشخصية مع قضية فردية
كانت وسائل الإعلام المحلية التي وصفت بعض النوادي
المتأثرة بنوادي المثليين ، وقالت مجموعات حقوق المثليين
إنه كان من الصعب على بعض الرعاة
التقدم بعد ذلك خوفًا من مواجهة
التمييز ورهاب المثلية الجنسية في
البلد المحافظ ،
أخبرني لي تشونغ هول أن هناك أيضًا  قضية
أسبوعين من الحجر الصحي حتى لو
اختبروا زبائن سلبيين سيحتاجون إلى
إخبار صاحب العمل أنهم كانوا في هذه الأندية
و  كشف عن ميولهم الجنسية ،
قدم رئيس البلدية بارك اختبارًا مجهول الهوية
يوم الإثنين ، حيث قال إن العدد الذي قدم طواعية
للاختبار تضاعف هذا
الحادث يوضح أنه حتى البلدان التي
يُنظر إليها على أنها ناجحة في التعامل مع
الوباء هي مجرد مريض واحد بعيدًا عن
تفشي آخر لا يمكنك أن تكون آمنًا على
الرغم من أن لدينا حالة جديدة  مجموعة من الحالات لفترة
طويلة ، لذلك وفي أي وقت
يمكن أن يأتي تفشي المرض إلى موقعنا ، يرى بارك أن
تفشي المرض هو درس آخر للبقاء في حالة تأهب
[موسيقى]
د.  عندما أرسل جون الذي وصف نفسه بأنه
سباح متعطش في هذا الفيديو ،
دعنا نلقي نظرة أحب السباحة
وهو تمرين جيد أحتاجه ولكن
جميع حمامات السباحة مغلقة ، سؤالي هو هل
يمكنني الإصابة بفيروس كورونا من السباحة في
بحيرة المياه العذبة وما مدى احتمالية الإصابة به  هل هذا
الطبيب عندما لا يصاب جون
بفيروس كورونا من السباحة في بحيرة أو
نهر أو بركة ولكن إذا كان هناك أشخاص آخرون من
حولك ويمكنهم أن
يتنفسوا أو يسعلوا عليك وهناك
أسطح يمكن أن تكون  عند لمسها
يمكن أن تصاب بفيروس كورونا بهذه الطريقة
ود.  ما الذي يغير أي شيء أعنيه
إذا كان شخص ما يسبح في حمام سباحة به
ماء معالج بالكلور ، أعني أنه في كلتا
الحالتين ، ليس الماء هو المشكلة ،
إنه التواجد حول أشخاص آخرين
بالضبط وأنا قلق حقًا عندما أرى
هذه الصور لأشخاص يتجمعون في
يمكن أن أتخيل أن هذا
يحدث في حمام سباحة إذا كان هناك
حمام سباحة عام وكان الكثير من الناس يلمسون
طاولات ومقاعد البلياردو نفسها والأسطح الأخرى
أيضًا
[موسيقى]
أنا طفح جلدي دومينيك ومنذ أن كنت في حالة
إغلاق  قررت اختبار بعض أنظمة التجميل الجديدة ،
وحلق شعري الأسبوع
الماضي والآن ولأول مرة في حياتي
سأحصل على مانيكير
وسأفعل ذلك بنفسي في غرفتي الأمامية حتى
نرى كيف ستسير الأمور
مرحبًا ، كيف نفعل ذلك ، نعم ، أنا
بخير ، ما هي أهم شحنة
قمت بها في المنزل ، لذا فأنت بحاجة
إليها لأنك تعلم ، نعم ، لقد وضعت أداة دفع الجلد في ملف وعاء ،
واستمر في التعمق أكثر حتى
أتمكن من وضع كمان صغير بنفسي
تستحم حاليًا في حالة غسلها أو غسلها
اغرف لأسفل نعم ، حسنًا ، التقط كل
الجهير والبشرة ، لذلك هذا هو المكان الذي
تأتي فيه المحارق ، فنحن نقطع بشرة جافة من
هذا النوع من رواندا التي تنزف بالفعل ،
لكنني أعتقد أن ذلك
قد يجعل أظافرك لامعة جدًا بشكل أساسي
مانيكير جميل ، دعنا
فن الأظافر سنقوم برسم طبقة أساسية ،
حسنًا ، هل قمت بنفخها ، يجب أن تتحدث
باللون الرمادي وتغمس في طلاء الأظافر ،
سأفعل الحرف مع النقاط لأن هذا
سهل للغاية وهذا ما أردت أن أكون
هكذا  أنت تعلم أن هذا سيكون
تحديًا ، لذا يبدو مثالياً وكأنني
لا أطيق الانتظار لأرى لك
ربما أراه ، لذا دعنا نقرأ الاختباء من هذا
الرجل في جعله رئيسيًا هناك بينما
أعلم أن معطفي أمر مروع ، هذا هو معطفي العلوي
، لم يحدث فرقًا  لكن يبدو جيدًا ،
فإنهم يرغبون في قضاء أسبوع واحد في الإقامة لمدة
أسبوع يا رب
[موسيقى]